In the credit card class, we can look at the pseudo
code, and find that it first sets sum, and count to zero.
That's already there. These lines are the same as what we
had before, for computing the sum of every other digit. The for
each digit starting from the right part, is getting pretty familiar
now. I'll keep the code for controlling the number of erasions in
place. But now, instead of just always adding digit to the
sum. I need to check whether the count is even or odd.
And before I even get the digit, I want to
make sure I remember the increment count. Now [SOUND], if
count is odd [SOUND], I add the digit to
the sum. Otherwise, count is even and if the digit
is less than five, I add twice the digit
to the sum. In the last case. Count is even
and the digit is greater than five [SOUND]. And I
want to add twice the digit [SOUND], and then subtract nine.
This is all just matching that pseudo code.
Now, instead of just returning false, I need to
return [SOUND] whether the last digit of n. Is
zero, or not. The last digit of n is
zero when sum mod ten is zero. For example, if sum were 24, then sum mod ten
would be four, which is not zero, and the card would not be valid. But if sum is
40, then sum mod ten is zero. And the
card is valid. So this would return true. Looks
like I forgot to change my pseudo code into
real code. Count is odd, if count mod two is
one. And now I'll run the tester. And it
looks like, for at least the examples that we've
used, my code is returning true when true is
expected. And false when false is expected. Here's some food
for thought. Does this guarantee that my code is correct?